all right
sonny brown hello atlas welcome to the
show
thank you so much i'm so grateful to be
here likewise
yes grateful to have you thank you thank
you bow to the divine in you
yes and you thank you
a show on magic mushrooms yes
much needed much needed as many as we
can get
yes yes so important
what an interesting
journey you have that
is very unique super unique
it's wild your lineage your roots are
wild and that upbringing and then
how it's sort of flowered into
your unique expression of what you're
doing right today
with healing hustlers that's right all
right
let's jump in let's unpack that journey
to walk us through sunny brown who you
were growing up
how you became who you are today okay
i would love to um so a little bit about
me
i started well i'm originally from
an italian and panamanian background
um so i already have a a wild
culture mix you can say i'm a little bit
of this a little bit of that
but i come from a mom
who gave birth to me at 15 years old
still in high school very young
and then a father who was 18 years old
and incarcerated for 12 years
soon after um so
at three years old one of probably some
of my earliest memories
i remember just having
some experiences with my dad this is how
i kind of knew that our memories
extended
uh beyond the age of like before the age
of three because i knew that um
i had solid memories with my father
and that was had to be before three
years old because he left at three
and so um yeah
so i i basically
uh remember us you know having
experiences like in a taxi cab where our
door flew open
and just like things that were kind of
like traumatic or my
our dog ran away and i remember that
vividly
and so at three years old he gets
incarcerated for attempted murder
due to something that was um a problem
that was going on with my mom and a
group of her friends he felt the need to
protect
and um had just an instinctual urge
to go and um
and attempt to shoot this man and so
essentially he did but he didn't kill
him so
they gave him 13 years in prison um
and then i was left to kind of you know
grow up and develop
without a father figure and a mother who
was
extremely young and you know she didn't
really understand
the the depth of what life really was at
that
that time um and so
yeah it was it was pretty difficult you
know
we moved a lot i lived in
uh probably over 10
to 12 different states throughout my
whole life
i started at three different elementary
schools
one consistent middle school three
different high schools
and it was just a lack of in lack of
stability
um but she tried to do the best that she
could so i never
i never blamed her too harshly for it
but amongst that i was still developing
a relationship with my father who
was incarcerated so
he uh he when i would go and visit him
he would spark these
these conversations between us that had
to do with spirituality
and they sparked because i would have i
would
have these inclinations to tell him
about experiences
that i was having that no one else
really understood
um basically seeing spirits and
you know having sleep paralysis
and really weird dreams of
beings and things that that weren't of
this realm
and i would talk to him about it and for
the first time
ever speaking to an adult they believed
me
he was the first adult to ever believe
me
and with him doing that he also
he started to communicate with me more
about what these things actually meant
he started to put seeds plant the seeds
into um
into what these things actually were and
and grow this amazing inclination and
curiosity for
what now is my my spiritual lifestyle
oh my gosh yeah so
yeah this is already really really
novel upbringing
where we don't have
many people that come on the program
that have a
a parent that becomes incarcerated for
their pretty much vast majority of their
of their upbringing first of all second
of all the
mother that's you know 15 years old is a
very very young time to give birth and
to become a mom
and to try and figure that out right so
those two things couple together and
then
it's really interesting how you get
these knocks like you're getting these
knocks when you're growing up of of
spirituality like there's more to this
than what is meeting the eye and the
physical
right equation right this mystical
this mystical curiosity that's being
planted
you know almost beyond your control
yeah and that the
thing that i told you as you were
telling me the story before we started
is that it's so
crazy that your father ended up being
the one
that even after such a
an experience and becoming incarcerated
that
he still
ended up reading these different
perennial spiritual texts
and gaining that and then becoming
the only person
in your life that was able to help
catalyze right your spiritual inquiry
but he was in prison exactly and so
that's so
hard when a nobody around you is
communing with these spiritual knocks
that are there and then
b the only person that is is your father
who's incarcerated
right and so essentially what what ended
up happening because he wasn't there to
nurture
really nurture the things that he was
teaching me is that
subtle seeds were created so i had the
i had the remembrance of what he was
saying and i
and i knew that he understood me but
then i would go back into a reality
where
that none of that was my truth you know
i went back into survival mode where
you know i was just playing outside with
my friends who didn't know anything
about this and i was back under a roof
with a mom
who this was too much for her it was
always too much for her you know
spirituality
it made her nervous and it just caused
her anxiety and she just didn't want to
touch on it so
i was so curious you know i
i used every moment of me and my dad's
time
like writing in letters or
just communicating over the phone when
we possibly could or
seeing him in person when i i did get
the chance to see him
to cultivate and and nurture
those questions that i had those deep
questions
and this is all within the age of like
six years old and i would say like
uh 13 6 and 13.
so you're getting a
an interesting spiritual education that
pretty much
i've never heard of before which is that
your father that's incarcerated is
right you're speaking
with him either in person across the
glass or you're doing letters right and
actually how the visiting was set up is
we could sit at a table
together so yeah like i can like hold
this hand and you know what i'm saying
yeah so we we
got to have that that physical um
interaction that i absolutely love so
much
um my only thing would say is it was
just a very limited time
frame and um and
the amount of times in which i got to
see him throughout his time of
incarceration
was less than probably six or seven
times you know
in totality jesus was mostly letters it
was mostly letters
and a couple phone calls
wow okay so
now okay so now you're experiencing
these
sort of spiritual knocks when you're
younger it's helping being catalyzed by
your father
and then your father's getting out
and he has this mission to basically
become a pinnacle right figure in your
life
and to sort of reclaim sovereignty and
reclaim
excellent fatherhood and to deliver that
as a promise
exactly so when my dad was in prison um
he was reading countless countless
amounts of books
like hundreds and hundreds of books and
one of the books he recommended to me
was albert taylor
soul traveler that helped me learn about
lucid dreaming
taking uh sleep paralysis which is the
first step of lucid dreaming
and learning how to um
basically excel from that point and so
it was little things like that
that he was you know he was taking from
the books that he was reading and then
implanting into me
before he even got home so then when i
uh was in eighth grade we got the news
that he
was able to come home early on good
behavior so it was
it was absolutely amazing like to know
that my dad was finally going to be here
in the flesh and my one
friend my one person you know who
actually had a similar mindset to me
was gonna be here and able to actually
help cultivate that
it was everything to me you know and he
was excited too
he was just happy to be reunited with
his family he was driven
um i knew he was going to come out and
do big things
and that's exactly what he did he came
out
he got home on good behavior he got
he went to college and he ended up
getting his bachelor's degree
in solar solar design and renewable
energy
and it was he became an electrician now
and he's doing amazing he takes care of
his whole family
he had another son which is like that
was like his goal his dream he knew he
needed another child he wanted another
child
but by the time he got home he was in
his 30s and he wasn't really sure
if um if if it was really the right
decision but he felt called spiritually
you know and i just watched how he
allowed his spirituality
to always lead him you know and so
he he told us that he was going to have
another kid with my stepmom
um mind you by this point we're all like
13
14 15. you know my older siblings are
graduating from college
um i mean not college they're graduating
from high school so um
it was odd to know that there was going
to be a baby you know a baby sibling
but he he was sure that it was going to
be the boy
that he always wanted you know he wanted
his son so
um it happened he he had another child
it was a boy just like
he said it would be everything that he
said he was gonna do everything that he
said
it was gonna be it was you know he
he's a walking manifestation and um
he's magic you know like seeing that in
the flesh
was so important because his story is so
dual you know it has so much
it has so much trauma it has so much
pain
um but at the same time like it
is so beautiful it's so magical it's
it has sacrifice it has unconditional
love
um and it set the tone and the
foundation for
who i am and and what i'm trying to
build and
um just
me helping other people cultivate those
energies within themselves
and maintain those energies you know
yeah what an what an important story to
be able to communicate to other people
that
even when you have some sort of uh an
early
sort of trauma in life that to be able
to realize that there's still so much
potential to shine
as a unique treasure and artist in the
world and
and contribute really powerful fruits to
family community beyond
i love that story and it'll be awesome
to potentially
be able to share it one day when he's
coming through that would be a lot of
fun
yes i would absolutely love that i'm
sure he would that'd be so cool he has
so much to share
um anytime i can really get him in a a
communal environment where
he could spread his truth um i'll take
it you know love that
i love that and to help catalyze that as
we were doing
in in san francisco with some of the
souls that were on stevenson street
right behind market street there's a lot
of important
uh work that we still have yet to do
with sharing the stories
of those that have had these types of
scenarios but also have bounced
and found those treasures i think is so
so important
right at the same time that your
father was writing to you you were
also undergoing experiences
that were slowly opening you up more and
more
through friends as well and even after
he got out
right you had these experiences where it
was like
either friends that you were working
with it was hard for you to find people
that were awake to
in to consciousness into into
spirituality and so you
you but you found some of that right and
that became kind of your avenues
for the continued compass towards your
north star
so it wasn't until after i graduated
from high school
that um i decided to move to virginia
and i wanted to do that because i wanted
i wanted to know what life was like
beyond the influence of what was
familiar to me
and family is familiar so i wanted
something different i wanted almost like
a clean slate and i know that of course
genetically
i can't clean my slate like that you
know
the best way to do it is just to kind of
strip yourself
from what you know and put yourself in
an environment where
you have to make your own decisions your
own choices
and everything is on you you know and so
i moved to virginia this completely
random place
uh new uh what was it called hampton
virginia yes
and uh i lived there for a year my
spirituality um started to skyrocket as
soon as i got there
i decided that i wanted to you know
focus on writing music i wanted to focus
on
um doing something that i loved and get
away from like
living like a corporate lifestyle and
just focusing on my passions i was
working as a waitress
and i had this amazing friend to this
day her name is
janae she i still keep in touch with her
to this day
um and she she
got me hip to some really amazing
information
one day i went over to her house and she
started showing me
spirit science videos and this is when i
was 19
and it uh it paralleled to some of the
things that my dad was teaching me
and this was the first time that i ever
had
uh friends you know
like like uh something familiar from
what he was teaching
up here in like my friendships you know
and
it was it was exciting it was
it sparked that that child that inner
child curiosity
and um i was interested in learning more
so i remember going home and just binge
watching
spirit science videos and like once i
got into the spirit science videos it
was just links
to you know oh watch the ralph smart
videos and
these are just fundamental spirituality
videos for anybody who doesn't know that
um that will just help you get inserted
into um into knowing
like you know basic facts about
spirituality and
um it was everything that i needed
everything that i wanted i was
interested in
learning veganism i started to study
minimalism so i got rid of like
all of my clothing and all of the things
in my house that didn't
that weren't of significant meaning um i
just stripped my whole lifestyle down
and i started i started new and the best
thing about that was
i wasn't only starting new inside
i was already starting new externally
too
so it was like a full detox yeah you
know
food mind no family
it was just me me and more of me
more of my own decisions and my own
choices and
um from that from that point
i started to attract more like-minded
individuals i started to attract my good
friends
derek and eric they
started showing me the matrix and the
four agreements and they
they took me from ralph smart and spirit
science to saying all right
you know i think that you can you can
get a little deeper with this i think
you can understand things that are a
little bit more complex
and mind you you know after i started
learning about that stuff
my dad he started getting more complex
so we started having talks about quantum
physics and
you know you know and getting and
getting into that and
i was breaking down the nature of
reality you know day by day
i love it and it was it was
life-altering it was life-changing
amen i remember starting to have
feelings though
that you know i wanted to wake up the
world
and the world wasn't moving fast enough
i was just like goodness like i'm a i
feel
i feel alone even though i have a few
people you know i want a community
i want to be able to walk outside my
door and
be in a different reality ultimately
and i'm like trying to find ways to like
break the matrix
take down government you know i'm doing
hard work hard studying every day to try
and figure out ways
to live off grid um
and that's how fast it happened from
within that one year
i went from you know
just having my dad teach me stuff as a
kid
and it being like these subtle seeds to
wanting to break the matrix yeah
it was deep it got deep
you speak about the
systematic process
of investigating the nature of reality
mm-hmm in that
that in essence is
the relentless
dedication to truth which
then it yields right
but we need to be that dedicated it's
funny we have
you know mick mindfulness you know is
like one of the
funny words that's used or like uh you
know sad gurus
talks about like i love sidekicks like
you know
yo you take 10 plus years to learn
language but you want to be enlightened
in five minutes
exactly exactly and i went through that
you know i was i think um
my my enlightening or enlightenment was
sporadic
um because i was i was experiencing
small doses of
doses of it since i was a child so once
i got a dose of it
it was like i was just
craving it at its its full capacity
and i think what had happened was um
you know i i shot myself through
things so so quickly and so fast that
i didn't grasp the full concept of
things um
and the thing is i was very self-aware
which
which i love um and i knew i didn't
grasp the full concept
of it so i told myself that i was going
to have to enter i was going to have to
re-enter the matrix
because to me what it had seemed like
was in this process of becoming a
different individual
i had pulled myself out of the matrix
and into my own bubble yeah you get what
i'm saying just so that i can
i can learn and so that i basically put
myself in a training boot camp
away from everything that i knew so that
i can learn but i knew i was going to
have to reintegrate
of course in order to see how well
i actually learned what it is you know
that i was studying like we were saying
you have to anchor the realizations
exactly i had to anchor and
i was doing these these things and and
not really knowing the full capacity of
what i was doing but now that i look at
back at him like okay you're you're on
the right track buddy
um but uh so so i go back into reality
and um yeah i lose everything you know i
lose everything that i built because of
some
choices i decided to go and rekindle
myself with people
who um weren't in the same alignment as
me
and it was
it was just a it wasn't necessarily a
bad decision
because it needed to happen but it
wasn't the decision that i
wanted you know it wasn't the results
that i expected
um so i remember you know i had bought
my first car when i was out there
and i lost my car i had um had my own
apartment when i was out there
now i'm back to living with my aunt
these are all based off the choices that
i had just made
and in the process of of
learning all this i
i learned that nothing is everything
happens
for a reason you know and if i don't
learn
how to be a hundred percent consistent
in my drive
of wanting more and wanting better for
myself
and wanting to be around people who
think like me a hundred thousand percent
like reflections are the most
important aspect of your life
surround yourself by those who are like
you
like-minded individuals because it's
just this whole reality this whole
matrix is just you
everything it's you you you you you
even these objects they're just aspects
of what you
think of them you know and so if you're
not around
like-minded individuals if you're not
around people that think like you
you're getting fed [ __ ] you know
you're getting fed
stuff that's going to leave subconscious
imprints that's right
and then when you're having thoughts and
they don't feel right
your moral compass is off you're being
led you're off you're off your path
and i learned the hard way you know and
i had to rebuild
um i ended up working i ended up moving
again because one thing about me is
being being that i had the childhood
that i had i was just
i was a sporadic spontaneous person here
there here there i moved often
and i couldn't really create like a
stable environment for myself
but i vowed that i was gonna stay i was
gonna move to maryland i was gonna stay
in maryland
for at least a few years and build what
i needed to build
and i did i stayed for three years
before coming here to la
um so i'm proud of myself you know pat
on my back
um and what i built within those three
years was
something bigger than i had ever or
could have ever imagined
um i started working for corporate att
and in the midst of doing that i was
dating someone new
um this person's sister was
involved in magic mushrooms she
introduced me to her medicine man
and um me and him grew an amazing bond
an amazing relationship and everything
else is history you know
as i birthed the healing hustlers from
that um
from working with him from having trips
working with the medicine which we can
get more into depth in
um but that
that interaction of my first ever
mushroom trip
is really what um
what rooted me in consistency
uh self-discipline shadow work
uh just self-love
and just perseverance dedication
i really enjoyed this
what we were mentioning before we
started where it's like
you have this time in maryland where
you're doing
corporate atn t and that's
simultaneously
juxtaposed with magic mushrooms
right and that in itself is such
a funny simultaneity
in what is a very much a
paradox in many ways and so it's very
beautiful that you got the essences of
both of those things because now
it makes it a lot easier for you in a
sense to also be able to relate with
people that are
in the corporate structures that have
that duality that have that
and you kind of you kind of act like a
a mechanism that's been there exactly
now in
drawing people into what is higher
states of being
exactly and so that that's really
important and then
the other sort of interesting aspect to
this is that
you you know going back it all makes
sense
when you look back and connect the dots
but at that time it's
it's so important that where whenever
wherever we find ourselves
in this journey and in this process
to almost be on the hunt
for finding meaning and finding the dots
that are being connected
because you never know when it's
uh your friend which i won't say his
name but you can if you if you think
it's okay to but yeah it's okay
you think so yeah okay okay that's him
yep okay
so we have who who it's interesting that
when you have the introduction be made
to somebody like that
we don't even really fully conceptualize
what it's going to catalyze
six months a year two years down the
line or even
with you know a full scaled
spiritual creation that ends up
impacting dozens and hundreds of more
lives
downstream so i think it's really
important to do stuff like that to like
try and and see that along the way
i actually agree i actually agree so
much that
um one of the practices that i've
started
well one of the practices that i did
work heavily with
is um creating timelines linear
timelines
where you can see moments of impact mois
you remember i was talking about yes i
love this
so so basically once i started working
with
um magic mushrooms after my first trip
i let's break this down i wanted to ask
you about this so the first trip was
four grams
exactly and then you started after that
you'll explain the experience but then
you started going weekly
you said you were disciplined to do
weekly and then you did
unpack the shadow work and all these
other processes that you
went through because that's what makes
you
uniquely able to do
the the healing hustlers
exactly so um so my first trip
was absolutely beautiful it um
it consisted of four grams of nepal
mushrooms
and i took it in the basement of
my ex's sister's house uh our ex's
sister space and
we we did it together she took like
seven grams
i did like four and at the time i didn't
really know too much about the dosage
you know i'm a beginner to this
i'm just doing whatever like i think
spirit is calling me to do
and i didn't think it was that much you
know from what
from what i thought at the time i
thought that that was a normal dosage
i didn't know that it was just a gram
away from a heroic dose
but now that i look at it everything
happens for a reason so it's no problem
at all
and i'm glad that i had that trip
because it was absolutely profound it
was beautiful it's magical
um but when it first started out i
didn't think that i could really feel
anything
um it had been well over an hour and
i i was such a like a logical
person it was hard for me to imagine
myself hallucinating
so i was just like i don't think i can
hallucinate like i think i'm just
i thought i was just too real you know
what i'm saying i was like i'm just too
grounded you know to to ever hallucinate
yeah okay well uh give me like 30 more
minutes and i start seeing i was closing
my eyes and i start seeing these streaks
of rainbow
and i'm like you know what i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go sit uh sit back in the
basement with her
uh and get you know get adjusted and i
started to get a little chilly so i sat
in front of the heater and i didn't move
for the whole night i sat i sat in front
of the heater wrapped in a blanket for
the whole entire night
and um i had next thing you know
i asked myself a question which um
it's so hard for me to recall because i
asked myself after i asked myself that
one question
i asked about a hundred questions in
about
30 seconds and i got all 100 answers
back in about 30 seconds and what were
some of the questions that you asked
yourself
i can't remember because they were they
were about the nature of the universe
and now i know i know the answer so i
can't
remember the questions just boom i just
know now yeah just kidding
it was it was more so like it was more
so like i wanted to know if what i
believed was true
and what was that and more so like um
you know are if i had to think of one i
guess i would just say like are we
um what are we yeah you know what i'm
saying are we really like
what are what are humans like those
types of questions you know
what what kind of society is this like i
wanted to know what i was in where i was
and
why i was here yeah and those big
questions like i wanted the big answers
and basically the totality of the
answers that i got was
you know i chose to be here and it
wasn't a
it wasn't like a a great detailed
response of how i got here
it was more so like a knowing yes i
chose to be here
and also i i realized that i was god
and then i looked at my my friend and i
said
oh you're a god too
wow i couldn't believe it
and i was getting all these downloads
about like she had a very
like etheric like um
like fantasy i'm the word is slipping
but
like fairy-like essence to her and i was
telling her that and i was just talking
her about her essence and
basically i felt just completely
connected with everything and i remember
one of the big lessons that
i got was no one can tell me
anything that anything you know you can
learn from the things around you but no
one can really teach you like you can
teach yourself
you have to go out and you have to
experience everything
100 you have to experience for yourself
and so i was like oh
okay well you know and then i remember
thinking
to myself i'm a new being like tomorrow
i can go
out and be anything yeah and the next
day
i woke up and i had to go to work
at my corporate job and that's so crazy
i told my boss that i got into a car
accident
i lied and listen i'm i'm not even a
liar i'm a hundred percent
truther i don't even believe in that you
need to go through
integration of the codes if you don't
integrate the codes then you actually
can't read baseline to those higher
states
so it's more important for you to
undergo this
process than anything else exactly
right and i knew that at a deeper level
so at this point
i just had to i had to be okay with you
know
not telling the truth because also what
i learned was we live in a specific kind
of society
that um that lies to us every day
and sometimes you have to mirror that
which is being mirrored to you
so that you can move through this game
you know
and it's not yeah i had i have a
sensitive spirit a sensitive heart so it
was hard for me to
integrate some of those things you know
what i'm saying it was hard for me to
kind of play
play that that gesture and um but i did
it i
lied to my boss or whatever and i took
off of work and i just spent the day
like in bliss that's right i spent the
day like just
enjoying what the [ __ ] i just found out
i hope i could say that
yeah of course i was like
this is this is this is it you know
this is it this is exactly what i needed
and my curiosity from that point on
was was skyrocketed and one i couldn't
even believe something like this existed
i was like i couldn't believe that this
wasn't something that was
in our societies i couldn't understand
why
you know the perception of how they they
present this in educational systems
everything is just completely backwards
it is the upside-down
world truly and so it just
because i was finding out how backwards
everything was
to to a true true extent even more than
we even know because
mushrooms are magic you know they're not
called magic mushrooms for no reason you
know
they're called magic because they they
get into the roots
of your your inner world and
change your whole outer experience and
that's what's crazy about it there's not
many things that can hit you on the
inside and out
you know except for for love and and
and epiphanies and things like that but
you know those are things that take time
and and
a lot of cultivation and in the society
that we live in
we don't got a lot of time especially
for those of us that are in survival
mode
you know we need things that are going
to shake us out of our sleep that's
right we need things that are going to
wake us up now
and so that's why i became an advocate
for
magic mushrooms my partner at the time
i had suggested that they do it and
i was telling everybody that i knew
everybody that hadn't done it before
my mom i did magic mushrooms with my mom
um wow yeah i i convinced her that this
is what she needs to do
and now she understands the importance
of it um she actually even
you know when she took it she actually
considered giving it to my sister who
was 13 years old
yeah but we're you know we're moving
step by step so powerful like that where
if you get a re-baselining to a higher
state of consciousness
when you feel one with everything when
you realize you are god when you realize
that the other is god when you realize
that
this is divine when you realize that you
came here you chose to come here when
you realize
the interconnectedness and
interdependence of everything when you
make these true embodied realizations
however it occurs whether it be through
the psychedelics and antiogens or
whether it be
through deep meditative experiences or
just simple
direct investigations of the nature of
awareness and consciousness there are so
many
ways to handle this but when those
codes become embodied there's such a
profound
shift that it's just
really interesting because when you
bring this gold
to family you know you you're
blessed because you have this experience
where your mother
undergoes a magic mushroom journey with
you
and then she's also interested in then
having her children
be exposed to these states of higher
consciousness
but vast majority of people
have the gold and they have nobody to
to come to with the gold and so that's
why you also
make these communities exactly yeah
exactly
and so just just kind of moving forward
you know
i was i was spreading the knowledge of
this throughout my family
friends anybody that i would come across
that would basically listen
and i was sharing my experiences
i had went through an experience with my
partner at the time
that was life changing in some some ways
traumatic
some ways very curious
some would consider it a bad trip that
that that person went through but uh i
was able to
observe it and um not i didn't actually
go through
quote unquote a bad trip myself i just
watched the person that was having that
experience
and um and in doing so it
it actually heightened my curiosity more
i wanted to know
about the duality of mushrooms now i
wanted to know okay
so now everything's not all rainbows and
sunshine
like we can actually we're actually
getting into the depth of some some
shadows here and where we're pulling out
some
some things that are shifting the energy
of the room
and so it it i wanted to learn more
about how
energy works um how energy is exchanged
throughout people so me and you looking
at each other right now we're exchanging
energy molecular energy and
um i want i want people to understand
how true that is like me and your
me and you we have an org field that is
mending and meshing right now that's
right and it's important to know that
those
those things are happening you know like
this is happening
like this just to help on a scientific
level just to ground this because
yes this is this is really really
important the synthesis of science and
spirituality there's many things that
are at play here
on uh on a scientific level we have
things like what the heart math
institute's currently trying to figure
out where you basically have
an field that is occurring
and you have this you have in your
cyanoatrial node you have these
pacemaker cells and that there's a
hundred thousand of these heartbeats
that happen every single day
and that every single one of those
heartbeats whether you
feel it or not those more sensitive you
get the more you can actually
feel it as well there's this massive
electromagnetic field that's occurring
every single time
right and that then you have another
sort of from a neuroscience perspective
a neurobiological perspective a
neurophysiological perspective what's
occurring is that
the way that i am currently speaking
words of meaning
are being translated by your senses
into chemoelectroconnectomics that are
currently occurring in your brain in
your physiology that are then
translating those into me
translating the meaning of it and your
own cognitive schemas and
representations of reality
exactly and so we are
literally physiologically affecting each
other as well as
even we just say words right to each
other and then you also get into some of
the epigenetic
stressors that occur too so when
somebody does
have some sort of massive anger stress
frustration and they're blowing up like
a volcano
right you if you get that fir
if you have the cortisol that enters
your body as well
you're creating literally epigenetic dna
methylation
alternate histone tails what's occurring
is that
you the more enriched and enlightened
you become the more you can literally
stop that epigenetic impact on your
body exactly and the more you can
re-baseline yourself to higher states of
equanimity
peace bliss joy and then the other
volcano
right becomes like huh they calm down
from your peace and bliss so they're so
many
interconnected science of spirituality
that's happening right now
exactly it's just really crucial to to
bring those
it's one of my main pillars is trying to
mine to
bring those together yeah right and i
think that is so it's so important
because that brings me back to moments
of impact
um what we were talking about earlier
before we actually started breaking down
how i got
to where i got with the mushrooms and um
when we are exchanging energy um
you can change you know my genetic
structure
and your you can change my my path
um my life path and the things that are
coming up in my life path
and do you mind if i use drawing i would
love to
yeah let's draw so so basically the
reason why we have it
right exactly what colors do you want um
i just i'm going to use two colors i'm
going to use this of course
let's do green uh-huh make them visible
nice all right
yeah make them physical okay beautiful
um all right
so basically what i want to touch on is
the fact that
um it's really important to know who
you're surrounding yourself by
um and the mushrooms will teach you that
i just want to say i'm so happy that
you're the first
person that we've had on the show in l.a
so far that has
through their own interest been like
i want to draw stuff now yeah and i'm
like i'm like hell yeah
yeah i'm so pumped it's so important
it's necessary it is um
because i think seeing this visually
will help um help a lot of viewers just
kind of understand where we're getting
at but
um like you're saying you know you you
want to try and
and create peace for yourself because
whenever you're
a moment of impact is basically when
something happens in your life that's
either very extreme
um positive or negative it doesn't
matter if it's
if it's positive or negative um and the
reason is
the reason that is so important and so
important to know about these things is
because
let's actually start with green um is
because
when you're on a path when you're on a
life path
and you're having experiences things
repeat themselves things appear in
pattern
and so if you have a traumatic
experience you're gonna
most likely have another traumatic
experience again
and it's just going to change the
character of who's
causing that trauma you know and this is
just how life works it's not something
that i can get too deep in if you
haven't had an experience yet
where you're seeing um life repeat
itself
like that um then i would just say pay a
little bit closer attention and just
wait
and just wait um because you'll see it
so
i'm super i'm super curious if
there's a deep resemblance potentially
between what you're currently talking
about and what you're about to be
showing us with what is in
chapter 2 c theory on high level
perception which
is that sort of trajectory towards our
star and how we can get
there's all these in the tree of
possibility there's all these
bifurcations and trifurcations that
occur in that
that those moments can be ones that drop
us more and more towards hell and
suffering or ones that bring us closer
and closer towards heaven and well-being
exactly and that's a more detailed yes
so for sure i absolutely love what
you're doing and
like i said i'll um i'm i'm grateful
that you gave me access to this
information and so
i'm going to be using it to just enhance
basically what i was already doing at a
more
a more miniscule or more actually i
would say
um i'm more like maximum uh
like grander view i love it but that is
a more detailed view and
even more informational can guide us
exactly where we need to go
so basically this is your life's path
right
it moves in a spiral and then also
yeah speak also in the mic and then once
you
finish also drawing that i'll show it on
the over-the-shoulder shot because
um it's slightly if or we can try um
if you want to we can swap
to this shot which will if you want it i
don't know if you can move it a little
bit more in shot yeah okay that'll work
for now okay so so far so far we have
you said that this is the this is the
life's path right this is the life
i'm gonna label it life's past okay so
that we can't we can't forget it
this is life's path right because our
life
life happens in a spiral it just repeats
itself
over and over again but it just changes
the characters in which we're
having these experiences right now with
every decision that we make
um at any moment we can make we can do
something really grand
or we can do something that really goes
against
our moral compass or or what feels right
you know on the inside
and so when that happens a moment of
impact is created so it's like a it's
like a line
right that goes opposite to the life
path so this is what it looks like when
a moment of impact is created
say it say it was created from the
moment she was born so like my
father going to jail at three years old
say that created that was created right
in the beginning of my spiral
right so this is what it looks like
right here in the beginning
right and say it affected me until
recently until recently i decided that
i i healed this and it doesn't affect me
anymore but
up until that up until that point i have
this
this trauma right that is going to
currently come back up on the spiral
and there's no way for unless you know i
know some
some people are into astrology and they
can kind of map out
you know when certain things are going
to present themselves but for the
average person
you can't tell when a trauma is going to
come present itself to you
you know this is just a this is just a
mystery that we're going to have to
we're going to have to prepare ourselves
for it it's no
it's no other way around it but there's
there's a there's a couple
things here first is the word
anti-fragility comes to mind which is
super important which is kind of
your ability to intake a stressor always
be prepared to intake a stressor
and be able to become stronger from that
exactly tell me if i if i'm interpreting
this correct
is it that this is birth here
yeah in the middle is birth right
exactly and then you
have this age three is when it hits this
drama
and then you have several more years of
your life until maybe and just a bunch
of other
a bunch of experiences and then you want
to heal
sooner rather than later and so maybe
you heal by 15 or something let's say
and then now 23 you're here at
where you're currently okay right and it
doesn't present itself after that
because you've already healed it and so
now you can move on to other things
but up until that point whether
something is very positive or very
negative
it's going to keep reoccurring in your
life and i think
that's why abraham hicks you know she
she talks about going back into the past
and searching for good moments
i think that that's so important because
a lot of us we go back into our past to
do
um to do shadow work in a way in which
we're
nitpicking at our past we're really
trying to you know we're trying to bring
it into the present so that we can
understand it more
and heal it which i think to some extent
is uh is okay you know it's okay to be
conscious and aware of it
but the present is a gift you know and
once you once you create this timeline
for yourself and you can see okay these
are these are the traumas that i've had
in my life these are
um these are the blessings that i've had
in my life you can come to
you can come to some middle ground you
know where you're saying okay
i understand my traumas i understand my
blessings
i'm going to maximize the blessings i'm
going to maximize the good stuff
and i'm going to learn how to be more
content
with the traumas that happen to me and
when and when they come
because i know they will because that is
how life works i'm gonna be content with
it
and the more you can be the observer in
these situations
instead of being emotionally reactionary
um my dad always says you cannot be uh
you can't be reactionary and are
revolutionary at the same time
so you have to choose one you can't be
angry and grateful at the same time yeah
you can't you gotta choose one
and so essentially um that's that's what
we're we're just trying to
we're just trying to stress here um with
working with the mushrooms with the
mushrooms it's a chance
for you to to re-baseline yourself to
to the highest potential of you to um
you know to get into the best state the
best
energy and from there what we do
is we're building communities and we're
building circles and we're building
centers and we're we're building period
um so that you have spaces to come to
to where you can consistently study
things like this
talk to people like me talk to people
like you talk to people that are your
reflection
you're not alone anymore you're not it's
not just you
and and this amazing epiphany with no
one to share it with
we're creating communities so that we
can stay
in these blissful spaces yes you know
yes and
and things will be difficult sometimes
but it's about having the community to
actually work through it
seeing or seeing the similarities in our
experiences and then moving forward
you know but it's in the teachings like
this and in the teachings
the detailed teachings of what you've
put together over the course of a couple
years
that we're really grateful for because
this is the
the revolutionizing of emotional
stability
spot on and then there's also
as you describe that this comes to mind
which is chapter four on portals in high
level perception
where basically when somebody undergoes
a profound
mystical experience like what you're
describing right they're basically going
through a portal to a higher level of
consciousness
but when they come out the other
side of that portal right we need
the net exactly we need a community
that helps them integrate right and so
what
what's happening in the black and
african american community
is they're having the epiphanies but
they don't have the community yet
so they're having the realizations
they're having the experiences
but then they're left to re-integrate
back into their daily routines
and what what we're trying to do is
we're trying to avoid that we're trying
to avoid going back to the mundane you
know
we're trying to avoid going if you have
to go back to your job all right i
understand that
but you still need to be surrounded by
like-minded people and reflections
because if you're going back to the same
friends yes you're going to drive
yourself crazy that's right
you know if you're going back to the
same environment on a on a
a major scale you're gonna you're gonna
really
um you're gonna separate from yourself
your mind body and soul they're gonna
start to separate from each other
because
your body isn't gonna trust you know
your mind anymore and your soul is going
to be craving
for your your mind and your body to to
get along
what really resonates with me from that
last bit
is that even if
you are undergoing one of these jumps
through the portal and maybe on the
other side of this higher state of
consciousness
that there is not a communal safety net
for you to land in
right away it's even more
important than if you don't have that
for you to
separate yourself from the
low quote lower states of consciousness
because you don't want to get dragged
back down
when somebody explodes like a volcano
when someone's angry or miserable
is yes eventually we'll get so good that
we'll actually be able to butterfly
affect
peace and love and compassion but right
away
it's really hard to be able to that
takes a lot
of a lot of work right it takes a lot of
work that's just like saying
that um instead of using psychedelics
we're just gonna
uh we're going to get to that epiphany
state through meditation
i'm like all right buddy it takes a
while i'm like all right buddy you you
guys you go ahead and you take the 10
20 30 years that it's gonna take to
reach that epiphany state go ahead but i
know that in the communities that i come
from
we don't have that type of time you know
we need to re-baseline ourselves to
higher vibrational
levels now yeah you know so and if it
requires that distance it requires a
distance don't
be scared to distance yourself from
family
from from friends and community that
just take time in an introverted way to
go through the the teachings that most
resonate with you like you were talking
about with spirit science or all these
other potential
um abraham hicks all these different
styles
of of grounding it further in your soul
but being away from kind of that more
central
part of the evolutionary pacer of the
bickering
and neuroticism and madness and
polarization and the gossiping
and the right all of those low
vibrational experiences
um we we're trying to we're trying to
basically recreate you know recreate
your life in a different way
that's just not so familiar you know
it's going to feel different not to be
around that energy trust me you know
i come from a family where that's that's
just what they do
you know and so i'm used to being around
that and hearing that but
i know that now because of what i
created that there's so much better ways
to use your time and to use your energy
and so it's just about you know being
okay with being okay with being alone
you know that's right because that was
something that we talked about prior to
even
starting this video and i think that
it's really it's a it's a big thing for
for everyone that's like a that's like
um
you gotta love yourself to be able to be
alone yeah mm-hmm
and you and you have to find yourself to
be interesting you have to find your
pursuits to be interesting
and you have to be okay with when nikola
tesla and so many people talk about
that being the secret of invention of
genius be alone
study the most brilliant people take on
what are
the most enlightened states open
yourself up to that
right and it's a lot of people don't
want to face that because it also
reveals a lot of things like
a lot of people don't want to look at
some of their most traumatic things and
that's that shadow work
side and so it's easier to say
bypass bypass right i'll distract myself
with company
and you know that was the main thing of
viktor frankl was that
that when humans don't find a deep
profound sense of meaning in life they
distract themselves with pleasure
yeah yep yeah that makes a lot of sense
and and my partner he has a brain called
of earth which you know
um you just had him on and um and
one thing that i love about that that
correlates to what we're talking about
right now is
it's a it's a universal human experience
you know
one thing that we can all agree on is
that you know
it's hard to be alone you know it's not
easy and even in the communities that
we're developing right now that's a
commonality that i see
between people you know
they are willing to compromise uh their
own spiritual development
and their happiness just to have
some company yeah to fit in and right
you're i like how you're bringing this
us back to this which is the solution
which is to drive more community
of those like-minded people where
somebody that is
uh whether they're black or arabic or
asia wherever they're from
that they can find people that are like
them that have went through the process
of re-baselining to higher states and
call that community where they can take
their gold
to them and say i had these deep
profound interconnected
states of awareness and then and then
they can share that
gold and the other person will mirror
that higher state
of being that i'm happy you're bringing
us back to that so the
burp the point being that we must create
those communities as a priority as a
north star priority
yeah that enabled the rebase lying to
the multidisciplinary
associations like dog studies aspect of
it which is knowing
where the person is at
psychotherapeutically before they start
right and then administering in a safe
conducive environment for them to
undergo the process
and then re and then that re-baselining
process afterward the integration of the
new codes
and so there's this multi-layered as
we'll talk about more
process and so is this sort of how you
found yourself
entering the space over time is the the
synthesizing of those codes into some
sort of
an experiential framework right it
definitely needed a framework
um i think that when i started the
healing hustlers
it was yeah thank you yeah until you
need it again
when i started the healing hustlers
basically you know
i had i i just started getting downloads
about different things that i wanted to
to do and i started to attract people
that wanted more from me you know they
were calling on more from me
um like almost like a mentor-like
position
and i didn't want to mentor you know i
didn't want to
to be that i honestly i wanted to just
study and observe
you know i wanted to study the medicine
experiences with myself
and the experiences that other people
were having i really
want it's working itself i'm i'm not
doing that you know and i don't want any
credit for that
i'm literally just a vessel you know for
everybody else to have a person to speak
to
i'm just like you just like a person in
the community i'm just another listening
ear
and everything that i'm giving you is
based off my own experiences too
but that's how life is you know and when
you realize that your whole society was
based off people's experiences
you'll be more open to listening to your
neighbors so i think that
just you know just teaching people
the fundamental natures of how our
society works
and creating more framework more
structures like you did
with um simplistic breakdowns of how
consciousness works and how it relates
to nature
like back to that word you know
perennial spirituality
we want to focus on you know the root
of spirit and i want to also touch on
this really quick
we have spiritual communities but
what i'm building is a community that's
based off of a mycelium it's
it's not just based off a spirit because
that's not all we are
we're mind body and soul so i'm not
building a spiritual community
i'm building a mind body and soul
community
that connects through mycelium which is
in itself both spiritual and physical
exactly it's spiritual and physical
which is beautiful it's the synthesis
of those two that we were talking about
science and spirituality exactly right
there
in magic mushrooms and we cannot
diminish the two
you know that everything is built off of
that and i think that um
people you know people in the spiritual
community sometimes can be
just like people who are not in the
spiritual community and and mirror each
other
when it comes to just like having very
strict code
and very strict points of view i do
things this exact specific way
but i mean once you start getting into
big dosages with this with these
mushrooms you're going to realize
there's not there's not too many
specifics except for the
except for universal law and natural law
you know
outside of those basics there's not
too many specifics actually things [ __ ]
is pretty crazy
you know and different and odd and so
don't try to put things in boxes yeah
don't try and put anything in the box
like
and don't be so judgmental of you know
a person who doesn't look and sound like
you yeah
yeah for somebody that is undergoing
their own anthogenic experiences i've
also been able to see
other people undergoing theirs and there
is a
wide color wheel of flavors
it is so white expressions i'm like
there's not enough colors in the ring in
the rainbow
i'm like as soon as i started taking
mushrooms like [ __ ] there's more colors
i'm like i've never seen those colors
before like you know that those type of
experiences so it's just like
all right you know it's time to be a lot
more open-minded
um and i think that i'm excited for the
new generation
me too you know because i think that
they're going to be a little bit more
um just unconventional a little bit more
yeah just just different and weird but
in a good way
you know weird in a good way and people
are gonna have to loosen their boots
because it just is what it is and and
where it's going to be double-edged
yeah it's going to be every single one
of
the advancements has the spiritual
ascent and decent have happened at the
same time
so the modern uh generation
z and the generation alpha that's born
in 2010 to 2025 which we'll talk about a
little bit with
right you as well um that
there is the double-edgedness which is
that we have the incredible
power for approximately 4 billion people
being connected at
the click of a button with information
technology across devices
yet at the same time there's these very
strange things of where
the ability for young people
to hone in and focus on something for an
extended period of time
or for there to be these sort of
horrible corrupt business plans that are
associated with the attention economy
that are mining at the youth
psyche rather than so but then we can
also leverage the technology to be able
to disseminate
the newest cutting-edge sciences and
decentralization
or in entheogens and you can do it in
little 15 second tick tocks there's so
many
great aspects to it at the same time
right so did
the double edgedness is because
especially you you're going to have an
experience in this
yes and just and just bringing that
bringing what you're saying in a science
term i think back to spirituality
how i see it is there's so many
dimensions stacked on top of each other
it's really just a multi-dimensionality
that you're speaking of
in my opinion like it's a it's it's
either you're existing here here here
here and here
but it makes jumping that much easier
because we have access to so much sure
so now it's just like this one video can
cause an epiphany in any kid
like my like just to tell a quick story
my little sister
has been watching you know what i do in
my work with the mushrooms for years now
and she wants to take psychedelic
mushrooms
really bad you know she's in ninth grade
at this point
going out going in 10th grade and she
she's ready
to to take them in her opinion and so
well her opinion is correct you know
then that's just that
um but but it's not up to me ultimately
so
what i'm getting at is she she was so
inclined that she decided to do
a challenge that she saw on um tick tock
that's called the nutmeg challenge
what is this so what this challenge is
is it actually
causes psychedelic experiences by you
ingesting
a certain amount of nutmeg oh sure
exactly well it worked you know she did
it and she and she told me about her
experience and then that was that
um but it definitely worked and you know
what i'm saying is basically
you know spirit is calling for expansion
and if if the conditions are right
it's going to find a way no matter what
there's more
besides the relationship with the
technological device this objective
physical device and the
my conscious agent experience with it
there's significantly more and so
whatever
the whatever the options on that buffet
are they're they're squeezing through
the cracks and they're becoming more and
more evident to people and then they're
going to go and explore those
at younger ages and then there's more
and more of the
well why does our social fabric
not biomimic the way that mycorrhizal
networks work with fungi and
and plants underground and so maybe that
two-way resource exchange can
potentially be the same way that we
architect a decentralized tokenomics
infrastructure for the maximization of
everyone's fullest potential
it will it has no choice it's already
actually happening but
i just think that it's not it's not
really that easy for people to see
right now but it's already happening
like psilocybin
is is an alien uh is an alien plant you
know it exists
in even outer space you can find spores
of psilocybin
and so it's an interesting theory yeah
about
our existence yeah so i just feel like
you know even right now we can easily be
breathing in psilocybin
you know very easily and slowly
that can be the reason why are we even
have
the amount of of uh
like differentiation in our perception
at all
you know what i'm saying so it's
happening it's it's happening maybe not
at the rates in which we
we may want it but it's it's already
here it's already working and
um when if the psilocybin wants to kick
it up a notch that's exactly what it's
going to do
what is the differences that you've
experienced
around the different uh processes
of growth of psilocybin and also the
different strains
and then the way that they affect
people's
consciousness and what specific use
cases
they're used for so i'll talk about
um let me tell i'll talk about a low
dose
low potency strain a mid potency strain
and high potency strain
um i'll say a a low potency strain
um just to think think of one off rib
would have to be like
maybe um
or like and i don't like to say low
because it's not really a low it's just
actually there's just like a midline and
then you get
and then you more so get into the higher
the higher uh potencies so like just
like a midline strain would be like
golden teacher
you know or um which is your nickname
right the golden teacher which is funny
yeah exactly um and the reason i like
golden teacher actually is because
i recommend it to first timers um it's
not
a high vis like highly visual strain
and the reason i like that is because if
you're going
if you're going in with the intention of
wanting to
understand more then
visuals can be very distracting you know
and golden teacher kind of just sits you
on your ass
and gives you a lesson you know just
teaches you
in a very gentle and mild way and it's
more
of you having these epiphanies within
yourself and these self-realizations
um now going
going up to some some bigger strains we
have like blue meanies
and um we have like albino penis envy
capes um regular penis envies
those strains right there you're saying
penis envy yeah yeah that's
yeah very funny it actually looks like
um it actually looks like the real thing
oh wow
well they kind of look like the head of
a clitoris or a penis yeah exactly
and nature's funny like that it likes to
uh
it likes to you know repeat itself yeah
everywhere
and it's just a very pattern-oriented
fibonacci that one point
exactly yeah golden ratio so
um so with those higher potency strains
um you're you're getting intense visuals
and you're getting intense realizations
one thing i will say is
the realizations can sometimes be
distracting with the visuals like
it's not like the visuals can be its own
thing and then the realization could be
its own thing
but then you're getting distracted by
the visuals so you can't focus on the
realization
i've had times where i was receiving
really profound messages
but like i had beings talking to me but
they had to keep starting over
because i kept getting distracted and so
i felt like i was on this weird loop
yeah i was like sure it was so odd and
um
but i was grateful that they continued
to start over
um and and still found that that that
getting the message through was very
important
um and so that's that's just why i love
mycelium i love
i love the even the higher potency
strains um
the message is going to come through you
know what i'm saying there's no way to
avoid that
and with those strains it takes a little
bit longer to grow
uh penis envy but for the most part it
takes about the same amount of time to
grow
um most strains i would say it takes
about within a month
you can definitely see you know the
grains start to
colonize and then from there you know
you're making the tub and then within
the
within the time of you actually making
the tub within
the next week to you know
two weeks you're seeing actual
colonization of the uh
of the the mulch of the um
why is the word actually slipping from
me but then and spores come up and then
yeah from there on
but i would say you have to give
yourself a good month this isn't a
totally this isn't a overnight thing
you know like growing anything like
growing any flower
um it takes time can you just get the
proper infrastructure to begin growing
yeah of course
yourself is it how what are the basic
infrastructural needs
so depending on how you want to do it
there's multiple
different ways i feel like the way we do
it is a little bit more complicated
because
we cultivate our own grains and
everything we do is from scratch but if
you if
that's a little bit too much for you um
you can just get grow bags
right online and there's a
there's websites like sporeworks and
just um
just other sites that will get you like
set up with all the tools that you need
and they come in full packages and works
will send you what you need
yeah everything that you need and then
how do you just do you just
have to plant it how do you do that
process how often do you take care of it
water does it go outside inside
it can sew inside so yeah there's
processes where
you would you would want to keep it from
light for a while and then
yeah and then expose it to just a little
and then expose it to light
and you would want to keep exchanging
the air and yeah there's
there's a whole set of set of processes
that also come with it
but um it's a learning process you know
what i'm saying if you're if you're
gonna if you're gonna do it
you're gonna have to you know tune in uh
tune into youtube videos tune in to
anybody in your community that's working
with it
and um and be patient because it's the
slightest thing that can uh
can kind of throw off your whole
experiment and we're talking
what we were talking before we started i
think we have
organs completely recreationally legal
right oregon's
completely recreationally legal um
colorado
dc those three are um
they're restricted decriminalized but
with restrictions restrictions
and so more and more of the also the
planet
countries at large are beginning to
undergo the process of realizing that
entheogens
are i believe the netherlands is
uh exactly the the netherlands for a
while now
has been at the forefront exactly at the
forefront of the
working with the medicine and their
crime rate is like little to none
yeah you know um plus they're
not not even to touch on their prison
systems but you know their prison
systems are completely different
and they look at people that are going
through specific things they look at it
as more of you know
needing therapy and needing more mental
assistance and learning more emotional
control and stability
versus locking these people up and
treating them like an animal because
when you do that
you just breed more of that of that kind
of behavior
you know yeah meanwhile the dea teamed
up with the cca
yeah exactly seriously that's what the
united states is you can't have
privately owned prisons
exactly and you you you have to treat
humans
like they have the potential to rebound
from traumas
and that that's the main focus and then
also we have the
exploration of the of the uh one of the
big things i would say about
countries that have lesser populations
of maybe 5 million or 10 million
population is that they're blessed with
that scale
that is an an order of magnitude
or sometimes even two orders of
magnitude less population
which then enables them to do things
like be a little bit more
intricate with each individual and doing
things like the complete
um recreationalization of the
substances and so we're definitely
heading that way also with all the
indigenous
perennial spiritual philosophies and
traditions
there's more and more of what's been
available to the higher states of
consciousness
across the different indigenous
populations
is you know how many more times do
people need to go to the amazon
to you know to be able to actually
you know ground what we're talking about
as these next generation architectures
to actually influence the systems that
enable
the next steps so that's become more and
more of something that
is at the core of my heart is that we we
must
actually create those next step
architectures
rather than keep going to i need another
next experience where's my next
experience
what next indigenous tradition do i need
to go and sit with i can't
stress that enough um i 100 agree
um where
where um the people that are doing that
are are people who are wealthy you get
them saying the people that are going to
have these
these medicine experiences in these
other countries um
they're usually like either middle class
or or wealthy people
um what we want to do is normalize this
we want to normalize it to research you
know this is a traditional thing and if
you want to do it the way
that it's always been done and carry on
those same traditions and respect the
medicine in that way
that's perfectly fine i have no problems
against that
um but you can do it here you do not
have to
you don't have to go to another country
to get specific fruits you know what i'm
saying the specific fruits are already
here yeah
and it's just about normalizing um
doing things within our own communities
and
and we just don't have the resources to
do that
um a lot of people where i come from we
don't have the resources to even do that
so that's not even an option for us
at this point we're we're making it
happen right in our
our homes and in our backyards this is
speaks a lot to the united states actual
code of law itself
because as much as we're upgrading to
what capitalism 2.0 is where it's more
of the inclusive stakeholding social
fabrics
as we can leverage the code of law that
exists
we can do things like entrepreneurial
entrepreneurially
make the changes that are drastically
needed
that that enable these types of
flourishings to actually occur because
we live
in that code of law that actually
enables people
to have the incentive systems that get
that fire under their butt
to flourish and it takes a lot of
sacrifice for people to move away from
that
you know that golden handcuffs of
working at a 40-hour
a week job to say that enough of this it
doesn't even
matter if i am making the couple
thousand bucks a month to pay for
everything if i am staying at the
stagnant level of consciousness that
doesn't serve me
i would rather drop the thousand dollars
a month
live in a car ask i did and do whatever
is needed
to re-baseline myself to higher states
and then the paths
themselves open up to architect that
next generation that that really opens
it up to
the communities and beyond too yeah and
my only thing is to
like um you know i'm not here to
to try and change everything you know
i'm not here to try and change the the
whole
fundamental structure of everything
because ultimately i believe that
everything is god
yes you know and i believe that the way
the universe is choosing to express
itself
is on purpose yeah and so right so if
it's supposed to be here right now
supposed to be here
but just playing our roles you know
whatever
whatever really guides you whatever
really fuels you then just do that
and play you play your role it doesn't
have to be so dramatic to the point
where
you're um you're forcing your opinions
on
hundreds of people that's not that's
never gonna it's never gonna work like
that
so allow people like i said allow the
mycelium to work
and it to come to you that's my that's
my best advice
allow um allow people to come to you
allow your community to come to you
and do more work on your manifestation
skills
because that's what's really going to
get you to the next level
and that's what's going to push you into
the next dimension a lot of a lot of
a lot of what we're talking about and a
lot of what people want it's already
here
the space is already here and there are
the communities are already built
they're just getting better better and
stronger and stronger but
they're here and they're working and
they can use more support
of course um but you have to be in that
frequency to access them
you know you have to be in that
dimension and in that space
to even access it
yeah and the link is in the bio below to
the healing hustlers on instagram and
you can find
that video that we watch at the
beginning and you can walk and you can
kind of check out a bunch of other
interesting thought-provoking content
around
this style of
of next generation upgrades in
in reality that were that we're
endeavoring into i want to i want to ask
you about
the two things with psilocybin
both pregnancy which is very interesting
we don't typically think of what occurs
when
we administer anthogenic substances
into our bodies when we have a child
growing inside of us which is super
interesting and then the other one is
with singing and where
we can tune into specific things like
when we were talking to sky we're
talking about the schumann frequency
7.23 or so at the vibrational frequency
plan so
can we get people like your voice can we
get that
tuned in at that natural we sure can
yeah
yeah we sure can so so just touching on
pregnancy first
um i'm actually four months into my
pregnancy
expecting in may and i've taken
mushrooms during my pregnancy and the
reason that i chose to do this is
because
i was driven solely based off the
experiences that i've
heard other women had within my
community and
i trust them you know i trust my
community i don't need
tests or a lab to tell me um
or administer you know approval for me
to do this and the reason that
you know i feel so strongly about that
is because we can see in our own
communities that you know we're
we're we're taking things like vaccine
vaccines and um
and medication that is harming us and
doing the exact opposite of what
uh what we need done for our bodies and
so
you know just in the way that i eat
living a plant-based lifestyle
and in the way that i take care of my
body um
i've i've you know developed a health
that is extremely extremely powerful and
much different than
most of my family and to me i feel like
that's breaking a generational curse
you know because i'm watching a lot of
my family
become overweight and be sick
from eating what they're eating and
living how they're living and
ingesting what they're ingesting and you
know drinking and smoking
but i'm living a plant-based lifestyle
and
taking mushrooms which isn't even
legal and i'm living a healthier
lifestyle
so that sounds pretty backwards to me
you know pretty backwards from what
we've been told and
if i know that that's backwards then i
have to question a lot of
what else is backwards as well that's
right and so my community
taught me that taking taking
the medicine while pregnant is actually
really good it's really good for the
child
we call them still babies they are
they're expanding the neural networks
within their brains
before even being born yet and so
as soon as they're born they're gonna
have uh
act very active neural networks and
they're going to be able to perceive
more than the average child is
able to perceive off rip
interesting this is in such a
fascinating spaces
administering antiogens into the
pregnant women and exploring
the potential augmentations and
perception
and in re-baseline to higher states of
their children
naturally upon birth and to sort of look
out for
this and map it over time and try and
scientifically through the method
actually be able to prove
that this is more efficacious i really
i find that to be super interesting
and that there's no fear that's
something that's really important
because the number one thing that sort
of
drives this style of conversation is the
fear it's kind of like the same thing
that
what people were telling uh henry ford
and like the whole model t
explosions like oh my god horses are the
best
don't do the cars don't do the cars
horses
and it's kind of that same fear
archetype that is
when anything new is happening with like
decentralization right now and
cryptocurrencies bitcoin ethereum
people are screaming right now stick
with fiat
stick with fiat it's the best it's safer
it's comfortability yeah so try and see
what happens when we aim to have these
newer experiences that right
are potentially much better and so
we must explore to know we must explore
to know
exactly and we know that you know the
whole
um the whole medical industry is just
ran solely off of of monetary
exchange and that's just not how my
community works you know
where we're barter we're bartering and
we're working together and we're
we're donating to each other and i think
that
um when you when you're doing things
like that
your intention for why you're doing
things is no longer
um rooted in this greed
you know because there's no need you
know we have we have an abundance of
everything
because we're we're giving to one
another effortlessly
and so um you know i remember my dad
telling me this great story about
medicine men in africa africa if one
person got sick within the tribe
he didn't get paid or she didn't get
paid and i think that that's so
important to highlight because that's
not how things work here
if people do not um cure
get cured it doesn't matter the doctor
still gets
their their payment and um this the
patient is still sick
and if that's the case then why would
the doctor ever have any incentive to
heal
that's right other than their own moral
code but
we can't just base things off of
morality anymore
you know we have to hold people
accountable to something more
and and that's why you know shifting
yourself to
to the reality that you want to be in
because we're already here we're waiting
for y'all
so shifting yourself to that reality and
um
and joining joining us you know in
creating abundance and just giving
effortlessly is what
is going to revolutionize um yes the way
things are done
that service to other evolution for sure
and then
hit us with some of the singing as well
so for
yes so for music um i've been doing
music since i was a child it's
just always going to be a divine gift
that i was blessed with being able to
channel
and knowing that what i know about sound
and
the frequency of 432 learning more from
my partner and knowing how things are
tuned to 440 hertz
and just knowing i've had some mushroom
trips where i've had
profound speakers speak to me through
the mushrooms about how
there is there is hidden
there's hidden messages in the
frequencies that
are subconsciously programming people to
move
in into situations and into spaces
that go against their their morality and
that go against their
um their internal compass and um
especially for black men and so that's
something that came through for
um for me through a trip uh when it
comes to the trap music
and um the just the
the culture of um
you know speaking just this low
vibrational
these low vibrational perceptions um
over these this music that's tuned to
440 hertz is deeper
is deep is deeper than we even know it's
deeply affecting us on a genetic level
and um the only way that you know we can
rewrite this
is by truly being ourselves and and
channeling the true message so the best
way to do that is for me to create music
that is tuned to the right frequencies
and essentially um you know
can be used in on top of the medicine
you know because i'm trying to hit
things from left and right
yeah because that's the that's the
intensity that we have to
we have to come at nowadays so a full
immersive experience
right visually auditorially exactly
tactics haptic inside and out and
certainly
yeah externally and and on a physical
level so
um you're going to hear you're going to
hear the sound you're going to see the
visuals
and you're also going to you're going to
have
you're going to have peace of mind
knowing that it's tuned to the right
frequencies and then on top of it
you're going to be getting the downloads
that you need to get
on a subconscious level this would be
also a good time to shout out brandon
howard and
euphoria app because that's what gives
us the ability he's
doing it right now with the psychology
of sound where you can just
literally tune in we just had him on the
show a couple of days ago where you can
just tune
right into any of these sophie or
schuman frequencies
for vitality or for peace or for
meditation or
creativity and so this is the future is
being able to leverage
this style of technology and like i can
just tap right into
sonny brown maybe i want to listen to
you specifically
and then that's the whole artist
integration component where i can
also potentially be like patroning
my different artists that i like
listening to at the same time
and so that's the whole sort of
inclusive future that we're
talking about right that's the new
generation having
having things at your fingertips um
you know there's there's a lot that is
in the media
that seems as if it's going against
exactly what we're going for
um but we just have to continue to
believe in ourselves and know that
you know what we're doing just doesn't
make the front page news but
it's being done just like you said and
so um
like i just every day you know i'm just
excited for
for what's to come because i know for a
fact
that i'm playing my part and my
reflections have to be doing theirs as
well
yeah you know yep what now two questions
what would you say
is the nature of reality
and consciousness what is specifically
the purpose of these
realities of the
the different realities like the the
layering the stack
the stacking of the realities is what
you're asking what would be the point of
the whole
um i honestly think
it's as simple as this
every day you know i wake up in this
space
that has so much possibility
right and i can do i can i have so much
uh to access right at my fingertips and
that's without the use of my imagination
yeah right so what if we include my
imagination in there
now i have the external world and a
whole internal world
and they say that i'm a reflection of
god i'm a reflection of the whole
so that's the purpose the purpose is
just like i wake up every day
and i have the ability to to tune in to
what's already here or to tune in to
what i want to create
the purpose is to to contribute to that
inside and out
you know is the contribution to life
itself
yeah one massive
creative expression that is eternally
expressing an essence of creativity
right and we we see it on a micro level
but
it's really just one thing doing doing
one
real infinite creative thing
it's just a dance you know it's just one
really long
um symphony one one never ending song
never ending you just have to ask
yourself what do i want to contribute to
it because i'm here
yep your instrument your melody
pick and play right
last question
what is your favorite food my favorite
food
um hmm this is such a tough answer
i i would have to say
oh i
i'm in such a confused space because i'm
sharing my body with a little being
who switches up my taste buds like every
day
like i'm like oh let me get some hot
sauce like
and some like you know and something
random
um so it's like i've lost like favorites
for things but
right now i can give you my favorite
right now my favorite
food right now would probably
have to be
i feel like like sweet potatoes
yeah yeah like yeah we haven't had that
that's a good one yeah
he just made them for for thanksgiving
uh
my loving partner just made them and
they were so delicious
and and sweet potatoes were my favorite
as a kid growing up like they're my
favorite
uh dessert sweet potato pie they can be
made for all of those different yep
and so right now like i can definitely
go for some sweet potatoes
at any point of the year it's super
they're so versatile yeah used
with not fries though oh you don't like
them in fries i don't want i don't want
the fries ones
now oh interesting yeah and interesting
i really like them like cut up sliced
and baked baked i love
baking them butters sprouts literally
like brown sugars salt is another one
yeah yeah
exactly and salt is good too um yeah
those are
but i'm feeling them i'm feeling them
that's that's my snack right now like
i'm feeling everything sweet potato-ish
interesting
and some and like next week it'll be
like something completely different
yeah yeah yeah cause a little one i'm
like i went through like a phase of like
a couple weeks ago arugula
yeah arugula it's interesting thinking
about scientifically
what the impact of little ones taste
buds are
on mom just dating little one so funny
kind of interesting yeah i'm curious
like nutritionally what does the little
one
call for what do you want what do you
want all types of things
very very odd combinations you know yeah
like
i was just thinking about how like i was
just snacking on some popcorn and i also
was eating a carrot yeah exactly you
know
i know i know
sunny this has been awesome thank you so
much
thanks for coming on the show thank you
for having me this was an amazing
experience
i'm so glad that you know you're
you're here to go into depth with our
thoughts
and our opinions like this and just look
at them so unconditionally and
open-mindedly
thank you so much this was such a
beautiful experience
thank you for allowing me to speak my
truth and you know to represent my
community
and i just want to tell everybody that
you know
i'm sending you much love on your
journey if you're tuning in and if you
lasted this long
and you know we're here to support you
so reach out to us
and um we're going to get you right
we got you yes we got you that was a
beautiful flowering
your aroma rocked
thank you i love it we're grateful for
all the work that you're doing
especially as the golden teacher
i love that i love that nickname it's so
good
and also the link in the bio below for
everyone again the healing hustlers
catalyzing spaces that use psychedelic
mushrooms and perennial spirituality to
share vulnerable culture shifting
conversations
again find them here
boom check them out the healing hustlers
yes check us out check us out super
educational as well like you saw in that
video as well which is
which is right here which is awesome
yeah
it's exactly kind of what we need to
take it to
the mainstream masses is the
the dissemination of the magic mushrooms
through the
edibles and through yeah this style and
yeah normalizing we're gonna normalize
it
yeah that's right and
also let us know your thoughts in the
comments below everyone on the episode
we'd love to hear from you
let us know what you think about all
things magic mushrooms all things that
sunny was teaching us let us know what
your thoughts are
also support them their links are in the
bio below to the healing hustlers
support
simulation our show like the video
subscribe share the video with people
that you know would be
impacted positively by this
especially those that need that little
nudge to those
next steps of higher consciousness do
that do that
and support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
scientists the engineers
all the people in your communities that
are building the future and manifest
your own
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in everyone
thank you thank you thank you so much
thank you so much
super grateful for you all right much
love
much love peace